[Music]
welcome back to las vegas now there is a
mask mandate back in place as kovit
continues to spread so we talked to
ant excuse me an attorney from eric
palacios and associates the sponsor of
this segment to get more details for you
take a look michael welcome to the show
thank you thank you for having us
absolutely okay so we're talking
mask mandate obviously this is a very
hot topic for everybody because we're
all concerned of
you know what are we supposed to do now
so let's just talk about first and
foremost what is
the new mandate yes the new mandate is
that starting july 21st
masks are required for all employees
working indoors
okay and what about tourists and people
who aren't working what do they have to
do
uh the mandate doesn't apply to tourists
or locals not working
although it is encouraged that all
people wear
masks while they're in public areas
absolutely it's getting very busy out
there in these vegas streets um when
will the mandate be over that's a lot of
that's what a lot of people are asking
how long will correct uh
and it's hard to know for sure it's
going to depend on future kovitz
statistics
we know that the city council is going
to have another hearing on this matter
on august 17th
to see if they extend the mandate or end
it
okay and do you have any suggestions for
the employees that have to wear their
mask now while they're working
uh yes definitely we know it's
uncomfortable
and tiring to wear the mask but it is a
mandate so
we all need to uh do our part so please
do your part
and we can all get back to normal sooner
okay
thank you so much michael we will
definitely stick with you guys to keep
us all
updated on this topic we appreciate you
thank you so much for having us
thank you to eric palacios and
associates for sponsoring this segment
and for that important update for more
information give them a call at
702-444-777
or you can visit their website at
erickplacios.com
las vegas now will be